- So check this out, I am going,
I just was in Austin,
Texas, I'm now in Boston.
I connected in Chicago,
I'm gonna speak right now.
I'm gonna poop and shower.
I'm gonna speak, I'm gonna
go directly to the airport,
fly to London, hotel, shower,
14-hour day,
sleep for four hours,
fly to Lisbon, Portugal,
shower, speak,
leave, fly to Boston,
Boston to New York, quick
drinks meeting, go to sleep,
wake up five o'clock
the next morning,
go back to the airport,
go to the Bahamas,
catch Summit at Sea, give
a keynote, dock in Miami,
land Saturday night.
Even for me, that is some
intense shit.
("Hotel Costes" by Jaylien)
Yeah, nice to meet you.
DRock?
- That is DRock.
- Hey, Soloman,
it's Gary, how are you?
I'm doing well,
thank you,
thanks for making some time.
The payment terms
are self explanatory
so I'll get (censored) up
front when I sign, right?
And then acceptance of work
is when I deliver it, right?
Yeah, let's put that
back to January 2019.
I can do it earlier, they'll
be fine with that, I'm sure.
if we all decide but,
what are you doing, DRock?
- [DRock] My job.
- It's nice in Boston today.
- [DRock] I like Boston.
Yeah, me too, I like Boston.
I think the other thing for
you to know is that my firm,
VaynerMedia, I continue
to build to be able
to bring advertising dollars
to platforms I believe in,
whether I invest in them or not,
and I definitely think a
lot of the candy brands
and the youth brands
are gonna, would find
a lot of value in
advertising on that platform,
so I believe monetization
can happen pretty soon,
and I'll personally
hand-hold that.
The Book Life, Venture
Capital Life and now.
Yes, Mark please,
it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
All right, Bye bye.
Almost client life.
Five more minutes, yo.
Very cool, okay, so yeah,
like I mean that's really it.
I'm sure you guys are super busy
but I'm very hungry
to kind of show you
what we've got and
really, especially I feel
like our friendship
has grown so much,
I'm thrilled to have
any conversation.
You tell me value prop,
cost structures,
KPIs, like let's have
those conversations.
I can really, I just wanna
basically drive it to success
and give you guys confidence
to do more and more with us
so I can decide if I wanna
lose money on this one
or create a different model
or have different models
in place, and we can
get into the details
of where and what and how
and so I'm very comfortable
with that conversation,
okay, okay, great.
Thank you so much
for the opportunity
to have the convo and I'll
talk to you guys soon.
Okay, bye bye.
That's how you do it, DRock.
That's how you fuckin' do it.
("Search Inn" by
Young Americano)
Nobody's run, you know,
when you walk in
and say, "We're
partnering with Vayner,"
even if we do this before
the announcement
and we say,
"Look, we're the first person
"to run an ad in the ecosystem
and all the other things
"that Jeff will put on
from bells and whistles."
It will mean something
and it'll put us
much further along the path
of actually doing something.
Hey.
- Hi Gary.
- I just texted you.
- How are you?
- Mmm, how are you?
- You want some water?
Sorry about the--
- No, I'm okay (mumbles).
I'm fine, how are you?
- Hi, I'm Lindsay.
Nice to finally meet you?
- Nice to meet you,
how are things?
- [Lindsay] Good, good!
- Oh, there you go.
- We're just gonna wait
for our security team--
- Okay.
- [Linday] And
then we'll be good to go.
- [Laura] Really
fascinating what you learn
about human nature and what
you learn about the awesome,
how's that for (speaks off mic).
- It's gonna be
very good, I think.
- When does it start over?
- April, we start filming--
- Oh, wow, that's a
still a ways out.
- Yeah, we start filming Monday.
- Okay.
- [Woman] That's the thing, I think.
I distinctly remember
and you barely knew me.
You were being video
interviewed at South-By
and I was walking by and
you're like, "Yo, Pistachio"
in the middle of the
interview and I'm like,
"Who has time for that?"
You know, like we have, I do a
lot of influential relations work
and so, you know,
some people who could
have giant egos don't.
- [Gary] It's true.
- [Laura] And lots of people
who maybe necessarily, you
know, maybe don't need to have
a giant ego do.
- [Gary] It's very common.
- [Laura] And so the
people who are super-classy
and loyal, I think, build
something around them then.
- [Gary] Is more meaningful.
- [Man] Oh, man,
I just snapped you two.
- Hold up, man.
- You got it.
- Talked to GaryVee,
he's out here.
- Oh, you went video.
- Yeah, man.
Say whaddup.
- Whaddup!
(laughs)
- What's up, man, hi man.
I've seen you twice, in
Nashville and in Dallas.
- Thank you, brother.
- You're the man, dude.
- Stellar, thanks, bro.
- Thank you, man.
- See you up top.
- Thank you, man,
looking forward to it.
- Hey Gary.
- Hey man.
- You mind if
I get a selfie with you?
- For sure, let's do it.
Oh, man!
- You're good, you're good.
- I have one job.
- Awesome, man.
- Thanks, man.
- Gary, my second-grade
teacher just joined
my Faceback Live,
say, "Hi Miss Briggs."
- Hey, Miss Briggs, how are you?
- GaryVee, Dance-hire.
How are you doing, buddy?
- [Gary] All well?
- Great to see ya!
- Good to see you, man.
- Thanks for joining us.
- Hope you enjoy it.
Thank you, hope you enjoy it.
- Rock it out, man.
- Thank you, man.
- We've gotta stop
meeting like this.
- We have to.
(laughs)
- Go get 'em.
- [Gary] I will.
What's up, man?
How are you, man?
- Good to see ya.
- Hope you enjoy it.
- Gary!
- Hey, man.
- [Gary] How are you?
- How are you doin'?
- [Gary] Good to see ya.
- One, two, three.
Thank you.
- Awesome.
You're welcome.
- Hi.
- I'm Kelly, actually,
can I hug you?
- Yes.
How are you?
- Oh.
(laughs)
- Okay, let's get a picture.
- All right, selfie or this?
- Yeah, we'll get a picture
and then we'll take a selfie.
Hold up.
(both laugh)
(woman mumbles)
- You ready?
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Okay.
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Can't wait to
hear your speech.
- Thank you.
- [Man] We've got a guy,
a blogger, I don't know
if you've ever heard of him.
He is the outspoken, saltily
languaged media entrepreneur
and blogger, Mr. GaryVee,
Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Gary] Thank you.
(fanfare music)
Good evening,
Inbound, how are you?
(audience cheers)
I'm super excited to be
here on stage tonight.
I thought a really
interesting thing
to talk about would
be self-awareness.
If I could spend two to
three minutes with all of you
and make you understand
that self-awareness
is probably the single
most important thing
that you can spend time
on, for your outcome,
for your future life, it
would be so exciting to me
if hundreds or thousands
of people left here today
and started really realizing
who they actually were.
What are you actually good at?
Are you actually in a
position to be successful?
What do you like doing
because the opportunities
are endless, the problem
is we are scared
to do different things because
the fundamental core reality
is we worry about
what other people think.
We worry about
getting judged if we fail.
One thing that I've
been very blessed with
is I've traveled the world
quite a bit for business
and speaking and one
thing that a lot of people
may not understand is
that entrepreneurship
does not work in
a lot of other countries
because failure
is a scarlet letter.
Here, in the U.S.,
we're so lucky
that entrepreneurship is
met with when you fail,
you pick yourself
back up and you go,
and to me, that is
unbelievable and we are blessed
to be in that
ecosystem and we need
to take full advantage of it,
thank you.
(audience whistles and applauds)
- [Man] What does it take
to get in there, man?
- [Gary] Send me an email
about the (mumbles).
("Building Something" by
Sam Heights &amp; Adam McInnis)
- [Man 2] Your video on turning
50 was fucking amazing.
- [Gary] It's going to
go away over time.
- Hi Gary!
- Hi.
- [Woman] Gary!
- Thank you!
- You're welcome.
- [Woman 2] You rock!
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
- [Man 3] Thank you.
(audience murmurs)
- Congrats.
- Say hey to everybody at home.
- So good to see you.
Hit me up any time if
I can be help to you guys.
- Oh, of course, well,
hopefully next time
I see you in Boston, you'll--
- I'm gonna try to do something
in Boston specifically
just to come up and
do a dinner, right?
Just like hang out so
maybe the three of us
will set it up.
- [Woman 4] That'd be fun.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm following you
(mumbles) going to the car.
- [Man 5] Constant
inspiration every day.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- Really appreciate.
- Thanks for saying hello.
- Thank you.
- Take care.
I really think that
the DRock backshot
is way cooler.
(woman laughs)
Get a selfie with me?
I'm giving dabs
to you daps, DRock.
Thank you so much, man.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- Bye Laura.
Heading to London, gotta
get some sleep in here.
Sleep is underrated,
I'm a believer.
Tough to come down
from that high of,
I don't know how you
caught that scene but
I know it was a
scene so good day.
Feel good about it, got a
lot of work to do, though.
You come from that
high of performance
to, clouds, to actually
business calls
and some emails and some
things I have to address
so that's the
reality of the game.
Thank you, buddy.
Got the keys?
- [DRock] Yeah, cool.
- See ya.
- [DRock] Love ya.
- [Gary] Love ya more.
Just wanna jump in real
quick and wish you guys
a tremendous Thanksgiving,
hope you enjoy
the football, hope
you're enjoying the food
but most of all, hope
you take this advantage
to actually speak to
your family and friends
about the things
that matter, right?
At Thanksgiving,
a lot of people complain.
They hold grudges, things
that happened 13 years ago.
This is the opportunity
to be the bigger man
or woman and take the high road
and remember that
the positivity of things
is always better than
the negativity of things.
And you can swallow your pride.
You can be that bigger person
and you can create that next
chapter of that relationship,
even if it's not the
relationship.
Even if it's your great
aunt, and you don't need
it to be the greatest
relationship of all time.
Just remember,
these people are not going
to be around one day and,
I don't know,
it just feels like
the right thing to do.